E
DURING THESE VERY DIFFICULT
DAYS.
A VERY EMOTIONAL DAY, SEAN, BACK
TO YOU.
>> Sean: GREG, GREAT REPORTING
AS ALWAYS.
BEFORE THE MONOLOGUE TONIGHT
SOME VERY SAVAGE NOMEX AVENUES
TO SHARE WITH YOU FOX NEWS
CAMERAMEN PIERRE ZAKRZEWSKI WAS
KILLED YESTERDAY IN UKRAINE
DURING AN ATTACK THAT ALSO TOOK
THE LIFE OF A 24-YEAR-OLD LOCAL
UKRAINIAN JOURNALIST NAMED SASHA
HELPING FOX NEWS AS A CONSULTANT
IN THE COUNTRY.
THE ATTACK ALSO SERIOUSLY
INJURED OUR FOX NEWS
CORRESPONDENT BENJAMIN HALL.
TONIGHT WE ARE PRAYING FOR
BENJAMIN SPEEDY RECOVERY.
WE ARE PARADING, COURSE FOR THE
FAMILY OF PIERRE ZAKRZEWSKI AND
SASHA AND BENJAMIN AS WELL.
KEEP THEM IN THEIR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS.
BECAUSE OF THESE BRAVE
JOURNALIST WE KNOW WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN UKRAINE.
THIS IS NOW BECOMING SPORTSTER
AND UNPROVOKED RUSSIAN INVASION
OF A SOVEREIGN COUNTRY.
NO ONE IS SAFE.
ACCORDING TO THE INVESTOR TO THE
U.N., THIS WAR WILL NOT STOP
UNTIL ALL OF PUTIN'S SPECIAL
MILITARY OPERATIONS ARE
ACHIEVED.
IN OTHER WORDS UNTIL LEVELED TO
THE GROUND.
AND THAT APPEARS TO BE THE GOAL.
SADLY UKRAINE IS LIKELY JUST
VLADIMIR PUTIN KNOWS WHERE HIS
TERRITORIAL AMBITIONS HOLD.
BUT HE HAS IMPURE THE ONLY
QUESTION THAT WE HAVE TONIGHT IS
WILL IN FACT VLADIMIR PUTIN, IS
HE CAPABLE OF GOING INTO THE
BALTIC STATES?
WILL HE GO TO MOLDOVA, GEORGIA,
WHO KNOWS?
WOULD THEY HAVE THE COURAGE TO
FIGHT BACK?
I CANNOT CONFIDENTLY GIVE YOU AN
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION TONIGHT.
THIS IS A CRITICAL TIME FOR THE
U.S. AND THE WORLD.
WE MUST MAKE LIFE MISERABLE FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND THOSE
CARRYING OUT HIS ORDERS.
HE NEEDS TO THINK TWICE BEFORE
PLOTTING ANOTHER INNOVATION.
HIS MILITARY HAS GOT TO BE
NEUTERED.
HIS ABILITY TO WAGE LONG TERM
WAR AND WESTERN EUROPEANS THEY
MUST IMMEDIATELY IMPORT EVER
THEY ARE ON RUSSIAN ENERGY
MAKING PUTIN AND RUSSIA RICH
AGAIN.
BY THE WAY, I WILL ADD, WE
SHOULD NOT BE IMPORTING OIL FROM
THOSE AND IRAN OR BEGGING OPEC
OR BEGGING THE MURDERING THUG
MADURO IN VENEZUELA WITHOUT
GETTING INTO WORLD WAR III.
WE SHOULD HAVE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND THAT THE SITUATION.
BUT THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO
STAND UP TO VLADIMIR PUTIN.
WE CAN DO IT AND WE CAN DO IT
RIGHT NOW WITH LETHAL AID TO
UKRAINE.
WE SHOULD BE SUPPLYING
CONTINUOUS SUPPLY OF WEAPONS,
EMISSIONS, CHAPLAINS, THAT
INCLUDES STINGER MISSILES AND
SHOULD NOT HAVE THE MIG-29
FIGHTER JETS A PLAN THAT BIDEN
PERSONALLY DECIDED TO KILL.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO ANGER PUTIN.
UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE ZERO FAITH
THAT YOUR GOVERNMENT WILL EVER
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION IN THIS
CASE.
OUR TOP THREE LEADERS IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT ARE ELECTED ARE
COMPLETELY AND TOTALLY UTTERLY
OUT TO LUNCH.
YOU HAVE THE DISASTER THAT IS
THE WEAK, FRAIL, COGNITIVELY
STRUGGLING JOE BIDEN AND
DISASTER AND TRAIN WRECK
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS WHO
HAS LONG DOCUMENTED ALL OF PUTIN
STRUGGLES AND KAMALA HARRIS'
STRUGGLES ON THIS PROGRAM AND
PERHAPS SHE IS WORSE.
OVER THE WEEKEND KAMALA HARRIS
AS EVERYBODY KNOWS PROUD THAT
UKRAINE IS A NATO MEMBER.
>> SO I WILL SAY WHAT WE ALL SAY
AND I WILL SAY OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, THE UNITED STATES STANDS
FIRMLY WITH THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE
IN DEFENSE OF THE NATO ALLIANCE.
>> Sean: NOW, THE WHITE HOUSE
LATER WOULD EDIT HER TRANSCRIPT
TO CORRECT THE FACT THAT FALSE
NATO REFERENCE, TAKE IT OUT
AFTER THOSE REMARKS THAT ARE
HUMILIATING HER TRIP ABROAD.
THE ADMINISTRATION PINCHED
KAMALA HARRIS FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE BECAUSE OF
ONE DISASTER AFTER ANOTHER FOR
HER.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID HE WILL
SOMEHOW MAKE HIS WAY TO EUROPE
NEXT WEEK.
LIKE KAMALA HARRIS, THAT IS A
PREDICTABLE DISASTER.
JOE WILL BE TIRED FROM HIS LONG
TRIP.
MEANWHILE, BACK AT HOME, OKAY,
WHO IS THE THIRD RANKING
OFFICIAL?
THE THIRD IN LINE TO BE
PRESIDENT, THAT WOULD BE
81-YEAR-OLD NANCY PELOSI.
AND SHE NOW APPEARS TO BE
COMPLETELY MALFUNCTIONING
HERSELF.
IF YOU THINK OPTION ONE IS BAD
AND OPTION 2 IS BAD OPTION THREE
MAY BE WORSE.
WATCH FOR YOURSELF AND YOU
DECIDE.
>> THEY KNOW THAT WE CAN'T GO
THERE.
IF PUTIN IS TRYING TO BAIT THE
TRAP SO WE GO IN AND THAT COULD
BE THE BEGINNING OF WORLD WAR
III.
PUTIN A RESPONSIBLE USING
WEAPONS THAT ARE NOT ALLOWED
UNDER THE GENEVA CONVENTION.
PUTIN WHO THREATENS THE USE OF
CHEMICAL WEAPONS, NUCLEAR AND
THE REST.
SO THEY KNOW THAT WE CAN'T, BUT
IT IS THE ASK.
NOW, THIS MORNING MORE IF WE
CAN'T HAVE A NO-FLY ZONE, LET US
HAVE OUR OWN.
AND WE NEED THE AIRPLANES TO
COME IN.
THIS MORNING, HE WAS LESS ON THE
ASK FOR THE POLICY, MORE ON LET
US DO IT, HELP US GET THE PLANE
SPIRIT BUT ALSO, THE
ANTIAIRCRAFT MISSILES ARE VERY
IMPORTANT WAY.
MYSELF, WHEN I SEE THAT, THOSE
TANKS, THOSE 40 MILES OF TANKS,
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE OUT THOSE
THINGS.
I THINK THEM HAVING MORE PLANES
MIGHT BE USEFUL.
BUT I'M NOT A MILITARY
STRATEGIST.
WE HOPE THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
GET TO A PLACE, I HOPE, I HOPE
THAT WE CAN GET TO A PLACE WHERE
THE MIGS THE KIND OF PLANES CAN
GO TO UKRAINE, THE F-16S
ESPECIALLY IN EXCESS OF THEM CAN
BACK TILL TO POLAND.
>> Sean: IT IS HARD TO STATE
THE OBVIOUS BIT BETWEEN NANCY,
JOE, KAMALA HARRIS, THIS COUNTRY
IS NOT IN CAPABLE HANDS.
PUTIN AND THE WORLD, I CAN SEE
ARE LAUGHING AT ALL THREE
SO-CALLED LEADERS OF THIS
COUNTRY, GOD HELP US ALL.
CONGRATULATIONS, NO MORE MAINE
TWEETS AMERICA.
YOU GOT WHAT YOU WANTED AS
KAMALA HARRIS SAID THIS WEEKEND.
LIKE MANY OF YOU, MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
THEY MISS A PRESIDENT WHO WAS
WILLING TO TELL THE COLD, HARD
TRUTH BUT TELL IT WITH
CONVICTION AND STRENGTH AND
FORTITUDE AND HAVE THE ABILITY
TO FIGHT BACK AND FIGHT BACK
HARD.
PRESIDENT TRUMP REPRIMANDED
GERMANY FOR THEIR DEPENDENCE ON
RUSSIAN OIL AND GAS BACK IN
2018.
HE ALSO LECTURED THE HEAD OF
NATO.
AT LEAST ONE WORLD LEADER
FINALLY A LITTLE LATE BUT
FINALLY SINGING A SIMILAR TUNE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE PROTECTING GERMANY.
WE ARE PROTECTING FRANCE.
WE ARE PROTECTING POLAND.
AND THEN NUMEROUS OTHER
COUNTRIES GO OUT TO MAKE A
PIPELINE DEAL WITH RUSSIA WITH
EVERYTHING, BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INTO THE CONFERENCE OF RUSSIA.
>> IT IS VITAL THAT IF WE WILL
STAND UP TO PUTIN'S BOWLING AND
AVOID BEING BLACKMAILED BY PUTIN
SO MANY WESTERN COUNTRIES HAVE
BEEN, WE HAVE TO GET OURSELVES
OFF RUSSIAN NATO GERMANY A
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF THE ENERGY,
YOU KNOW TO RUSSIA AND TAKEN
CARE OF BY RUSSIA.
IF YOU LOOK AT IT, GERMANY IS
THE CAPTAIN.
>> VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS BEEN LIKE
A PUSHER, FEEDING AND ADDICTION
IN WESTERN COUNTRIES TO
HYDROCARBONS, OIL AND GAS.
WE NEED TO GET OURSELVES OFF OF
THAT ADDICTION.
>> Sean: NOW TWO YEARS LATE
FOR THE NATO ALLIES AND WESTERN
EUROPEAN ALLIES AS HE IS NOW
BEGGING THE SAUDIS TO PUMP MORE
OIL.
SAUDIS ARE NOT PARTICULARLY
HAPPY WITH JOE BIDEN RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE HE'S TRYING TO DO THIS
DEAL BROKERED BY VLADIMIR PUTIN
WITH IRAN,